So here is a snapshot of our code. Now, we know that when we
downloaded Twilio, we got, among other things,
a folder called twilio. And inside that folder
is a folder called rest. Inside rest, is a python file, which has a
class called TwilioRestClient. Now, when we say
rest.TwilioRestClient, with those parentheses after the class name,
what we are really doing is calling the
init function defined inside the class. And that creates
an instance. We call that instance client, and
then we do a bunch of stuff with that
instance, like send SMSes. Now, we know that
TwilioRestClient is a class. And we've seen another class
before which is class Turtle. Let's figure out
if there are any similarities between these two classes.